- In August 2001,
the press descended on the town of
Bury St Edmunds in south-east England.
The mayor was going to unveil
the world's first Internet Bench
here in the Abbey Gardens.
I'm not sitting on the bench
for a couple of reasons.
One, I can't get close-ups of
it while I'm sitting on it,
and two, it looks like quite a lot
of the local bird life
has been perched above it recently.
Anyway, "internet bench" sounds ridiculous,
but you have to remember in
2001, there were no smartphones.
Wifi did technically exist,
but it wasn't widespread.
And mobile internet was limited
to a few specially coded,
tiny black and white sites,
which could be accessed
slowly and expensively
on just a few models of phone.
If you wanted an internet
connection in 2001,
your computer had to
be plugged in somehow,
you couldn't just expect to
check your email in a park,
and thus: the Internet Bench.
A bench with sockets you could
plug your computer's modem into,
and dial up to the
internet over a phone line.
Which is weird, right?
'Cause surely the sensible
thing to do, even back then,
would've been to have
one internet connection,
maybe an ADSL line,
and then share it like a
regular corporate network,
just plug in an ethernet cable
and you'd have a connection.
But no, you had to use a phone cable,
and your laptop would have to dial
a regular landline phone number
to connect to... well. Who?
Launch day photos make it very clear
who you were supposed to connect to,
or at least it would,
if the mayor had realised
which way up stickers
need to be on a laptop.
This was all a publicity stunt for MSN,
the Microsoft Network.
And there are some very nice
quotes from MSN staff
in the BBC article about it,
which were probably pasted
straight from the press release.
In truth, this wasn't
really an internet bench,
it was a bench with a couple
of phone extensions run to it,
and that was it.
For a three-month trial period,
you could dial up to your own
internet account from here,
and it didn't take long before some
local tech-savvy teenagers worked out
there wasn't any block on the numbers
you could call from here.
The bench just had a
few phone sockets
wired into the exchange
at Microsoft's expense.
So, of course, they made a couple of
international calls for free
and tried to get through to Bill Gates.
They didn't manage it,
but they did get a nice
write-up in the local paper.
And one of the most wonderful
early-2000s posed photos I have ever seen.
From a technical standpoint,
this bench was a disaster,
but MSN were probably happy with it.
They'd have been happy with
the teenage hackers, as well.
It got their company
name in the paper again.
They're probably still
happy with this video,
even as I tell you it was a terrible
half-assed idea. Because what it did,
and what it's still doing,
was get their name and logo
in front of an audience.
They just want to be noticed.
That's one of the dirty secrets
of public relations.
If you want to get the
attention of the press,
if you want your brand
in front of the world,
you don't have to actually
make something good,
or useful, or sensible, or that even
works like you said it would.
The truth is malleable.
You just have to tell
a story that resonates,
get the press in to take some pictures,
and figure they don't know enough about
the subject to ask technical questions.
And then after you've
got those column inches,
or these days, the retweets and clicks,
you can basically abandon
the whole project.
The public are fine with it.
It's a silly story that doesn't matter.
The press are fine with it.
They've got content and
sold the adverts around it,
and it doesn't matter if
it gets ripped apart later,
as long as it doesn't kill or maim anyone,
then you got your free advertising.
And we've seen this
time after time after time.
Heck, I've done this
occasionally in the past.
That's not even the same bench, actually.
It's the right location,
but it's been swapped
out for a different one
with a couple of plaques on it
and no phone sockets.
But then, the bench working
was never the point.
This wasn't about connecting
the town of Bury St Edmunds
or blazing a trail into the future,
it was about getting cheap advertising.
And here I am, 20 years later,
still giving them that,
because World's First Internet Bench
still gets attention.
Oh, someone sat in it.